today's video is going to be all about
the National Lottery and if you're a
number freak like me then the National
Lottery is great because it's that two
times a week when all the people at home
get to share in my enthusiasm for
numbers so what I want to do today is
talk a little bit about some of the
probabilities involved in the national
lottery so before we start I think we
should choose some numbers for our
lottery so our first number is going to
be the number 14 that's my birthday then
I think we'll have the number in
nineteen that was a good year for me
we'll have a few in the 30s 31 and 33
and 34 okay and then one more 45 so I've
chosen the number 14 for my birthday the
number 19 and then if you're in the
thirties number 31 33 and 34 and number
45 so now what are the odds of us
picking those same six balls out of our
homemade lottery kit first of all to
start with there are six scores there
are six balls in here which are winners
for us and there are 49 balls just like
the national lottery game okay so I'm
going to look away and I'm going to
select and it's number 19 a six out of
49 okay so we put that one to one side
but now there are only 48 balls left in
the basket and we've got five winners
left in the box okay so you give that a
good stir around and it's the number 45
okay put that one to one side and again
now we've got one less ball in the box
so we're down to 47 balls and just four
winners now
good scare it's the number 31 and that
one again goes to one side with our
other winning balls just 46 balls left
in here now and only three winners there
it is to number 14 okay again got that
one on one side give ourselves a little
stir now there's only 45 balls left and
just two winners now it is the number 33
okay so we've got one winning ball left
in the bucket so give it a stir there it
is the number 34 okay so my chances of
picking out the number 34 were just one
from 44 balls and there we have it what
were the odds of me winning the lottery
and retiring to become a part-time
physicist well let's have a look at it
the fact the chance of getting the first
number was 6 in 49 then it's a
completely independent event so we can
just multiply that by the chance of
getting the second number which is 5 in
48 so and just multiply that then we
multiply that by the chance of winning
the third number the top line we can do
in our head is simply 720 okay the
bottom line I'm gonna cheat I'm gonna
use calculator 49 times by 48 times by
47 times by 46 times by 45 times by 44
and that's a number that's a number of
10 billion and change so we're going to
write down our 10 billion here so that
gives us our final answer in math speak
if you like of 7.15 1 times 10 to the
minus 8 that number doesn't really mean
anything to most of us and so I'm going
to write this as 1 over 1 3 9
eight three eight one six so the odds of
winning the lottery are one part in
thirteen million nine hundred and eighty
three thousand eight hundred and sixteen
or in real money about one part in
fourteen million I play the lottery at
Christmas actually I find it to be
really good fun so I tend to spend about
a five or a year on lottery numbers and
for that one week that I've bought a
ticket I daydream about all of the
really cool things that I'm going to do
if I win the lottery say how much is
that worth I don't know I really enjoy
it I really enjoy just the process of
owning a lottery ticket but I know I'm
reasonably numerically grounded I know
that my chances of winning and very very
close to zero I think my chances of
being struck by lightning a something
like seven times higher than my chances
of winning the lottery say I'm kind of
hoping that doesn't happen so we've won
the lottery we've matched six balls
that's absolutely fantastic but it
doesn't really explain why every time
I've bought a lottery ticket
I've not matched any balls at all so
what's the probability of buying a
lottery ticket and matching no balls
let's go back to the numbers that we
selected so we had 14 okay so these were
our magic numbers okay so what are the
odds of selecting a first number which
doesn't match well there were 43 balls
in here out of 49 which don't match so
I'm gonna select one there's number 38
okay so that doesn't match I don't want
that one there I remember here we go
that's the number 35 and again
it doesn't match
it's the number 25 again no use to me 41
out of 47 okay so the next one I'm a 23
getting a little annoyed with this
that's no good to me either so the
chances of putting out a non winner
there were 40 out of 46 okay do another
one I've got the number 41 no use okay
so the chances again 39 out of 45 and
our last ball well don't think it's
going to be a winner that's for sure
hope it's not a winner
number 43 okay so we've got no balls at
all rubbish
right the chances of an on match 38 out
of 40 if we calculate this number
through again I'm going to turn to my
calculator okay so our probability of
picking no matches whatsoever is 4
billion divided by 10 billion which is
sorry 43 percent for three point five
nine six four nine percent somebody is
spending a pound a week playing the
lottery and for that pound a week
they're getting hope and excitement and
a Saturday night buzz that's great value
to be honest so that's fine but if I
hear of somebody who's spending 10 20
quid a week buying lottery tickets stop
please stop